the time being 10 past 12 past 10 we'll
get started
we've got a few I think we've got a few
substitutes today that we'll just uh
introduce
um over on the side over here we have
representative nodder
and um
who else do we have
preposition
representative uh Cole come and uh
Representative Steve Smith will be um
here in a little while filling in
okay thank you so we're going to open up
with a work session on HB 15 which is
relative to the rate of the business
and and by the way I'll just make a
comment that um
as as many of you have noticed our exec
session starts at 10 30 so we'll be
bouncing back and forth between after 10
um once we finish a work session we'll
go into exact session executive and then
go on to the next bill so
um given that it's not 10 30 out if we
finish HP 15 before then we will
continue on the work session in
numerical order here of house bills and
then Senate bills so um did anyone have
any
all right yes
representative plett
so this cuts the business Enterprise tax
from 0.55 to 0.5 and I'm always in favor
of
reducing taxes where we can and still
meet Revenue requirements for the state
um that we already have a a speed up of
the interest in dividends tax passed
into law through the hb2 and so I think
this is not ripe for prime time now and
be taken up in the next biennium
thank you
anybody else
all right seeing none I will close the
work session I don't have a gavel but um
close that close the work session on HP
15. it will come back and exec this
later
all right I'm now going to open the work
session on hb60 camping fees for
non-residents
and do we have any
okay
simple enough
I will open the work session on HP 100
which repeals the interest in dividends
tax
representative plett already in HP 2
Ergo this is uh
not ready for prime time it's already
passed this might speed it up some but
uh from the from what's in hp2 but I
think what's in hp2 is enough for this
representative Ami
I'd just like to point it out that if
you could
you would be
in the middle of a tax year and that
all right anything else
seeing none I close the
work session or HP 100.
we'll now open the work session on HP
relative to worldwide combined reporting
for unitary businesses
under the business profits tax
representative spilsbury
thank you Mr chairman I'd be glad to
give a report on behalf of the
commission
um we've held a an organizational
meeting again with new membership on
August 15th
and I was selected to chair
and of course representative Schamberg
and representative ulery are on the
commission
eight of the 15
positions on the commission have been
filled as far as appointments and we're
simply proceeding with seven vacancies
because we do have a quorum and we've
had active participation from all of
those who have been appointed
we
we asked to meet several times during
the summer but we were denied permission
to do that only allowed an
organizational session
and we agreed at that meeting to meet
twice in September September 5th and
September 25th the September 5th turned
out to be very problematic lining up uh
presenters on the day following the
holiday
and so after some back and forth we now
have a very full agenda set for next
Monday
the 25th
we we're going to start at 9 30 in the
morning run till probably three in the
afternoon we have five presenters in the
morning we'll take a break for lunch and
three more in the afternoon
these include in-state business
Advocates of the bill
includes representatives of
international multi multinational
businesses include academics include
experienced administrators from two
other states
so I want to give credit to Gen 4 for
doing a terrific job backing me up and
lining up I think a very potent agenda
about half of them maybe a little more
will be in person
and the others will speak remotely
because this is an issue that we don't
have a lot of direct experience with in
New Hampshire so those who are expert on
the subject are calling in or even
traveling from long distances
we've decided to stream it
and anybody who's got the time either
during or following I would encourage
you to at least pick and choose some
pieces and get a rough orientation it's
a complicated subject we have a deadline
of filing our report no later than
November 1st
at this point we anticipate just this
one very full day of testimony and we're
going to try to accelerate our report if
we can we'll know we'll we'll know that
better you know after the 25th so my
objective is that
the Ways and Means Committee defers this
until you can hear our report
and I would anticipate that we would act
on it this fall
so if we can get that report into you by
October 15th we'll certainly try and
we'll keep you posted
thank you
representative almie
thank you could I just ask a question
about that streaming on is
is there frequently the streaming the
person who is testifying or the person
who is calling in I don't know how
that's going to work is not audible to
those of us who can't come in person
and thank you for that question I've
asked the same question uh
representative army with that concern in
mind and I'm told that we shouldn't have
any difficulty with the audibility
combining the streaming and the remote
testimony we might have a little bit of
limitation when it comes to slides
people who are watching on the stream
may not be able to see those or read
them
so anyway these have been addressed and
thank you
representative Platt yes this is a
non-jorn German comment if anybody ever
sees me grimacing it's got nothing to do
with anything said
and whatever party or any anything from
the audience I just went through my
second back surgery for spinal stenosis
the first one was successful I was
allergic to the stitches though so I had
to be opened up again so I'm not in
terrible pain but I feel a little so
forgive me if you see me making faces
that aren't appropriate
anybody else have anything else to say
on HP 121
yes representative Ames
yeah I'd just like to say that I'm I'm
uh reassured by representative
Spielberg's report I know it's been a
long time coming it's been a struggle
getting it going and it's an incredibly
complex subject matter and not without
uh different points of view so I welcome
what you're doing and I uh I wish you
luck in the limited time that you have
available to you that's that's the
problem I've done enough time thank you
anything else on HP 121
all right seeing none I closed the work
we'll open the work session on HP 133
relative to repealing the communication
any
comments questions
statements
all right saying none we'll close the
we'll now open the work session on HB
145 relative to the collection of sales
taxes of foreign jurisdictions by New
comments yes representative
this comment that when the wife uh Fair
decision was initially heard uh several
years ago this committee uh as it was
then uh constituted had uh uh long and
pretty exhaustive hearings regarding
that
um the uh the bill as presented was one
of the methodologies considered by the
committee but after uh intense input by
the uh Attorney General's office uh a
different bill was eventually passed out
of this body and eventually passed by
the uh the entire house
affirmed by the Senate and signed by the
governor to uh set up a methodology to
predict uh individuals there are some
really really
complex Interstate constitutional issues
dealing with uh
um this this type of legislation
um
period at this point
thank you representative almi
yes
um I've got something of an update on
that from the National Council on State
Legislature and and state and local
taxation meetings I went through the I'm
going to get people this report somehow
soon
um but on the
the Supreme Court of the United States
when it decided for the 45 states that
have sales taxes on
on in both the opposing on
on write-ups and the the decision itself
on recommended but did not require on
on specific mitigations to the Wayfair
situation which we're always already
being done by the test case that they
use South Dakota
um that is that
you
you have to have sent
um
I can't remember now but a a fairly
large for a small business
amount of
um
of product into any state in order for
that state to be able to come in and say
you have to pay us the sales tax on it
and they put in also which was worrying
that
you might
um you might you'd be able to do that if
you'd had 200 transactions for that
state if you were selling cheap earrings
on the internet you could easily get
more than 200 with nothing near I think
it's a hundred thousand the amount of
money
so
and California actually requires five
hundred thousand in recognition of the
fact it's a very big state but
on this was just made as a
recommendation a number of the states
were already doing that almost all of
the states have now moved to go to those
recommended levels
on including the
um and and the I think all but two of
the states that are left are in the
process of doing so
uh the problem with those two is that
they have in their constitutions that
every single locality is allowed to set
and that the state can't tell them what
to do about it
so that's Colorado and Louisiana
on the
but
the other thing that we've discovered
over the years because the bill that we
put in was a trap for anybody that was
going
on going below those levels oh and a
number of the states have already gotten
rid of the 200 transactions as well
because they've all decided it's useless
um but the
the ones
the the
um
the
businesses over a hundred thousand at
least most of them would be in the
category of large businesses for most of
these States California still might be a
problem
um but the Attorney General's office
on has control of a trap which is that
they look uh every every now and then
they look at um
at business organizations to to tell
them whether the any of the businesses
have complained about this yet
and
um
so far there really haven't been any
complaints but in the process also
they've learned that a lot of the bigger
businesses had already before Wayfair
been paying the sales taxes to other
states because they decided it would
cost less than litigating it
so we're we're in a kind of equilibrium
situation now
on which could change as we get further
away from federal stimulus and such but
that we do have a track bill for
and what that trap does is it says okay
if somebody comes in and is insisting
that the guy that
um
sold to bed one bed in Colorado or
New Jersey for uh
for 88 000 dollars
one of the people from The Craft sphere
uh and he got
a uh notice from them that he had to pay
the sales tax on that afterwards which
would mean that he would have to take it
out of his own pocket because he
couldn't go back to the buyer
then the Attorney General's office can
look at that decide whether it's worth
going to the Supreme Court to fight to
get
the conditions in that the Supreme Court
so so that's
um pretty much where we are on that and
I talked to
I am now cooperating on other things
with the person who was the head of the
streamlined sales tax fight that Norm
major and I were doing for
seeing none will close the work session
all right we'll now open the work
session on HP 192 relative to the rate
and exemptions of the interest and
The Spill would reinstitute the interest
in dividends tax any comments from
anybody
I kind of figured you might want to make
a comment representative almi that's
pretty much your bill
um this bill
is
is the the interest in dividends to X
will be repealed on the 1st of January
and would have to be reinstated
I am bringing in a bill to do that
so
um
that one is in drafting right now
because when we get to fy25
where there are a lot of things that
have been done to our taxes in the last
six years
on that
that can cause us extreme trouble even
if we don't have a recession
but we are losing the
um subsidies we've been getting out of
the federal government at just about all
levels of our economy
so
that's just what I wanted to say all
right thank you anyone any other
comments on HP 192
saying none will close the work session
we'll open the work session on HP 220.
establishing a committee to study the
regulatory structure of charitable
gaming
yeah that's uh I'm the prime sponsor of
that Bill maybe the only sponsor and um
I believe it's uh the need for it is
superseded has been superseded by the
establishment of a commission that's
addressing the changes in charitable
gaming laws in recent years
um which is just getting going
um and has a year to work so
um I'm hopeful that we will do good work
and in the meantime this bill is not
all right seeing none I closed the work
we'll now open the work session on HB
450.
relative to removing the net operating
loss deduction limit on taxable income
under the business profits tax and on
this one
um
dra has proposed or has helped us
propose
three possible amendments to this bill
handling it in in different ways looking
at the right now we have a 10-year limit
on how long deductions can be taken
looking at changing that to
to something longer looking at the 10
million limit we currently have on the
net operating loss looking to make that
larger and also looking to I believe
right now there's an 80 limit
on how much can be deducted looking at
changing that so there's three
amendments and um
I would ask that uh Keen Wong if you can
from dra if you can come up here and
tell us about the three amendments
you all should have a copy of these
three amendments on your desk
they are for HP 450 we have uh
did I say that right two two seven three
eight two two seven four eight and two
two seven
2 h
Keen introduce yourself I'm sure
everyone knows who you are but yeah
good morning my name is Keane Ming
welcome to Texas policy council with a
dra
good morning my name is Lauren
O'Sullivan I'm a senior financial
and um just to give some context we will
approach to uh provide some other
options uh for the nol deductions uh one
of the option was to maintain what was
in HB 450 but of course uh with the uh
incorporating uh all the previous work
the non-corps to also uh enjoy the uh
the repeal of the 80
um limitation and the other options uh
was to one of the one of the other
options was to remove the uh to extend
the 10-year carryover of the nol
deduction to a 20-year carryover and
excuse me interrupt you for a second if
we could talk about the specific
Amendment
um
so that if we start with for example
2272 h
describe that just so that people
understand which
yeah why don't you take my three I got
okay so we'll just go in numerical order
starting with 2272
okay
so amendment 2272h is essentially
similar to the original HP 450 other
than on line 26 which is where we uh
edit the additional Amendment there to
allow the non-corps to be treated the
same as C crops
so the the biggest
um
original Amendment or the biggest piece
of this bill is in the original
Amendment which is on lines seven
through nine which is uh they're
eliminating the um
the limitation that's
available on the current
um Internal Revenue code that is
so right now the the we believe
um the Internal Revenue code is what 80
right now but that's is that going to be
changing the engine are able to code
that that the uh that the BPT is
following is as of December 31st of
2018. and that is has that limitation of
that um 80 percent
with this um original HP 450 removes
that uh that limitation of the 80
and line 26 allows the uh
the removal of the limitation to be
applied to also the non-corps
okay
uh thank you yes representative
um I'm a little confused and I hope I'm
looking at a series of
typos so starting on line 13
yeah it's not a typo that's
that representative that is the original
text on the RSA the amendments to the
original text are in bold and in italics
on on this amendment we'll move on to
yes representative
um Mr King if I understand this
correctly you're now treating
um
subseas and llc's the same
so on the
yes that's essentially what's happening
with the the new the new language with
the language in here yeah correct all
yes representative Platt I did not hear
uh Mr Wong
um what the impact of this is
financially is it possible to determine
yes uh when this bill was introduced
back in the previous session a fiscal
and um so that was distributed in with
the previous HP 450 when it was done uh
for for when it was prepared it was a
million dollars or 1.3 million dollars
reduction in um in Revenue in fiscal
year 23 a 5.1 million dollar reduction
in Revenue in fiscay 24 and fiscal year
25 onwards it's a six million dollar uh
reduction in Revenue
um
potentially these these uh fiscal impact
could potentially be more of a timing
concern as opposed to a permanent
difference depending on how businesses
perform they may make potentially in
future Years be able to still claim the
net operating loss deductions that's
been limited to the 80 percent
representative Army
thank you but but this was just for the
C Corps
uh if we add the llc's
I believe this calculation was on the
total the population of the uh
the BPT population that we have
right
yeah
yes that calculation was based on the
total BPT population that we took the uh
and we've probably I think when we did
the the Cal Vision back then we made the
assumption that it was intended for the
entire population and not limited to
just C Corps yeah
foreign
anybody else have any questions on this
amendment
all right seeing none let's move on to
um
amendments
amendment 2273h is an amendment to
extend the uh availability to carry over
the nol deduction from a 10 years to 20
years right now the current uh
New Hampshire statute is limiting the
nol carryovers to only 10 years and then
this one allows it to carry over to 20
years
uh the the IRC of 2018 which is the uh
the tax code that we follow for the BPT
does not have a limitation on the uh on
representative Army
could you show tell us where the
differences between
450 is introduced and and on 73h sure
the 73 HD amendment is on line 14.
so essentially what we did with the uh
2273 H is we use the original language
as as is right now without the 80
limitation oh I mean without the removal
of the 80 limitation and just uh update
that for the 20 years carryover
so this is all based on the original S
as is currently uh the statute as is
current
representative Platt
uh oh I'm sorry you follow
um yeah do we is there a reason why we
have to keep
sub a through e
after well EES but the a to d it's only
age after it's been done not necessarily
it's probably mostly for
historical references
other times we don't yes representative
Platt do you see a practical impact of
this if you have a net operating loss
for tax purposes going Beyond 10 years
up to 20 is that a viable business
that was one of the questions that was
discussed uh when we were approached uh
with this uh potential Amendment and um
it's
it's hard to say
yeah
representative yes on
I think that
only a occurs when you have a large
business that has sub businesses that
they acquired in order to have a loss
that they could take off their taxes
yeah
and the question that I haven't thought
through is what this does to that but
also my question is does is
are
a to d affected by changing it to 20
um
excuse me representative could you
repeat the question please yeah what
we've got now is that we've changed 10
to 20 in line 14. and from line 15 to 22
it's saying the amount of loss generated
in tax for
year maybe that may be carried forward
may not exceed 1 million some of my
colleagues who are lawyers may have
figured this out already
and and then on Eve we changed change it
um
if they were obeying in from 2003 to
2005 and up until
2012 on the earlier 10-year level
would they
have more loss that they can bring to us
now
retroactively
that is these companies that
have a loss leader among their products
there so potentially potentially yes but
then with the prior years let's say it's
having a look at
um D so that carry forward amount is
limited to one million dollars
um
so it was 10 it was 10 years
after July 1 20 2005 probably
um you know July
2025.
um
it could be a nominal impact
with a with a one million dollar on a
but if they actually had twenty thousand
20 million dollars of net operating loss
I mean the fact that we're not
well I'm just wondering the fact that we
are not using the word retroactive here
I mean I'm reading this as
um if you're like on the on the ninth
year or the 10th year and this this goes
to 20 it means that you can just keep
you can keep going I don't really see
where this would be retroactive
yes
yes thank you Mr chair yeah I would
agree I don't think it's retroactive
number one number two I think this would
allow us to maybe Draw Bigger business
into New Hampshire
and help our tax base and help our state
uh just based on the fact that if a
business wanted to come in and start up
it would cover it would be able to cover
its losses if there were any as it goes
forward and grows and becomes
established so to me it looks like a
good Amendment thank you
representative elmik we have an awful
lot of research out there that says that
taxes are somewhere around the 9th or
10th consideration of large corporations
we did have a um
uh I don't remember it was a report or a
comment from I believe the tax
Foundation saying that um
New Hampshire ranks as one of the worst
in the nol
um area net operating loss our policy in
that regard so that that is something
that I would think they look at but um
any other any other comments
representative spilsbury thank you Mr
chairman I just would like to
confirm we will revisit this bill and
there will be an opportunity to discuss
specifics on another occasion this fall
is that correct because if so I'm going
to withhold my comments till then
that would be the plan and let's um
after a hearing from
um
Mr Wong people feel okay we're on top of
this we want to move forward
um
but if that's um so
I don't know how do people feel in
general right now feel like they're
going to need more time to digest these
or we could potentially
could move forward when we go into exec
session and and choose
one or more of these
representative Ames
yeah I I feel that we this is just uh
coming to us and that uh it is
complicated and that
um we all should take time to digest it
and then have a discussion that's
informed by a little time to think and
that that's what I recommend and I hope
we'll do it that way okay representative
spilsbury yeah yes I agree and just to
confirm exactly what I was trying to
apply I would
look forward to another work session on
this bill okay
representative doors uh I also concur
thank you Mr chair I also concur with
Representatives Ames comments and I
would like to ask representative all me
to submit to us those 10
they're listed 10 things that businesses
are looking at I would love to see that
so thank you
that's going to require a lot of work
right now
my information is you can I I can can
call a colleague and ask him yeah all
right
um all right any other any other
questions or comments on 2273
all right seeing none let's move on to
the last Amendment which is 2274 h
and so for the last Amendment oh yes
before I continue although the area
helped to prepare these amendments I
just wanted to reiterate that oh I want
to mention that dra does not have a
position on any of these bills okay
um so for uh Amendment 2274 H the
amendment here is to remove that that
limitation of 10 million dollars from
the nol deduction carryover
and that amendment is online 25 through
27.
representative plant just a practical
question do we have businesses with
anything else representative Schoenberg
thank you Mr chairman as being the
original sponsor of the first nol
two years ago uh I feel that what
representative janigan has done is a uh
a positive
overall
there are cyclical Industries and
non-cyclical and I think that we need to
make sure that uh
we are
being able to help them also the
especially the cyclical Industries
and
uh
when I first proposed my nol it it only
wanted to change that 80 percent
but I think that this ends up being a
better bill with your
amendments unless we have stronger
discussion later on when we meet that
would maybe change my mind
um
we are trying to provide an Optimum Tax
climate for this state and I think this
bill will add to that in the long run
but we need to discuss as representative
balmy brought up you know the a through
the D portions of this just to make sure
that we are not stepping on a landmine
with the retroactive so uh I do like
your approach to this
thank you
sorry could we get on
a rough fiscal note on each of these
thank you for the question
representative we did try to perform a
calculation on on these amendments
however
um the data that we have is restricting
us to actually perform any kind of
okay
question yeah uh representative Ames
I was just looking at my notes on this
bill when we
heard it uh initially and at that time
I think uh the if it was we were told
that there was a report by the federal
Congressional committee that had worked
on the at the federal level on this nol
issue regarding the 80 percent
limitation and the indefinite carry
forward question and I had asked at that
time if we might get a copy of that King
I don't know whether
you could look again see if there is
such a thing and if so either give us a
link or
yes representative ulery
just I'll ask a question when you
uh could we ask dra if we can get an
the 277s that are listed A4 uh
13 and a120 just so just
so we have in the back of our mind how
these match in with this
just
briefly because you're making a
reference to another section of law
um
section 172.
of uh the Internal Revenue code but that
that changes so
just I if I remember correctly 77 a120
says we're going to follow the code to a
date sir
that but then what is 172 just just as a
memory
device yep representative Laurie that's
correct all right RC 77-a1 Roman 20
states which Internal Revenue code that
the BBT would become in compliant with
for any particular tax year and section
172 that is the Internal Revenue code of
section 172 and uh so in online 26 to 27
here it makes reference to section 172
of the IRC of uh that is very compliant
with the 77
A1 Roman 20 so this would be the
Internal Revenue code 172 which is
relating to the annual deductions
uh that is
active
uh as of the December 31 2018.
yeah I I I remember the discussion and
everything I was just looking for a
mimic uh to
trigger memories and and so that the
members of the committee have that in
front of them it just you know
yes thank you sir
representative almond yes
um do you need that praise
also in um
70 72h
online 20
or should this be in the definitions of
the tax law if we haven't put it there
that when we're talking about 172 we're
talking about as of date
so
you're referring to 2274h
right so uh no I don't think we need to
because it says here that shall conform
with the r with 172 ircs provided in
77a1 Roman 20 and going back to
um 77-81 Roman 20 that specifically says
Which tax you so it depends on which tax
you're
we're looking at so uh 77 A1 20 mentions
so it's assumed uh adjusted by this
section so right it does go back to 20.
uh Mr chairman uh in answer to the
listing uh representative Almy brought
up it was Moody's Analytics of 2021
uh on this stimulative effect of
different changes that included the
inner well and Phil sledden on the New
Hampshire fiscal he also included on
page 40 of January of his report of 2023
so
there is information out there yeah yeah
Christmas reliable right let's stick it
all right thank you very much
we'll now close the work session on HP
450.
I was originally going to kind of go
back and forth between work session and
exact session but I'm thinking we may
try to just finish through this work
session and then go into exactly that
makes sense yes
all right so uh given that I'll open the
work session on HB 494 relative to fees
collected under the New Hampshire
fertilizer law
comments representative all me thank you
I really think that we need uh
commissioner Jasper
to talk with us about this because we
have a dedicated fund already which is
supposed to cover fertilizer analysis
uh fund 44 in the 612 list
and
um
it is apparent in the report
on that in the 20 2022 dedicated fun
book that uh the report from agriculture
is that there is a lot of concern in the
department that they are unable to carry
out enough of the functions of that
dedicated fund on
and fertilizer seems to and liming soil
amendment seems to have been a
one of the losses
from that fund
but the question is should we start
another fund or should we
um
provide more money for that fund
or just forget about something that is
very important to Farmers and to people
thank you
um yes this one we we will have another
work session on this one because we are
going to need to hear from commissioner
Jasper and potentially
um or potential others but before we
make a decision on that so given that
we'll have another work session I mean
unless someone has something to add
right now we'll probably move on
yes representative would you want
senior represent commissioner Jasper I
must tell
just a little bit too late that we were
doing this today and it's my fault on
and I don't know if uh represent bitsky
Bixby would like to to say anything in
um
foreign
when I put this bill in I was unaware of
the existing dedicated fund that
representative all me uh as referenced
uh at this point uh the fee income from
the from fertilizer and liming goes to
the general fund and uh if it's uh if
this bill can be amended to realign the
that distribution to the existing uh
um
a dedicated fund and and uh work with uh
the commissioner to make sure that uh
the the requirements under RSA 431 are
being addressed uh then that would that
would uh be an ideal solution I think
that probably requires a further work
session thank you okay thank you thank
you
all right so we will
just comment
again on agriculture is meeting with the
dedicated fund committee at some point
uh in the near future it is one of those
that's been having trouble finding a
time if I remember correctly but
but um
we should be able to get it done before
okay next meeting okay all right sounds
good I'm going to close the um work
we'll now open the work session on HB
relative of the State education property
tax and low and moderate income
homeowners
property tax relief program
okay thank you
so on this bill uh just to start with a
I believe it would be
good to defer
um in depth
discussion until later in October
um
reasons being that there's litigation
going on that may come to
to a close with a Judicial opinion this
direct would be directly on point to the
part of the bill that um
but that uh you know in effect does away
with the so-called excess swept uh issue
by uh requiring payment of all swept
Revenue into the uh State funds uh it
won't go into the details of that but
instead of being collected and held
locally it would be all uh deposited uh
centrally in this state treasury or with
the dra
and there's an exception in the bill to
that with a new allowance for the costs
of collection that is provided for in
the bill at three percent per amount
collected by locality and that's you
know to try to compensate in some some
way for the effort and work that the
localities do in collecting this money
for the state so it's a it's a big
complicated Bill and it also has a low
and moderate income tax feature to it
and we need to talk about all of that
but I hope we can do that later on I
would say that I know there are
two people in the audience
one is uh Zach Sheehan from the New
Hampshire school funding fairness
project
who is on top of the
latest status of that lawsuit that I
mentioned and I'm not sure there's more
to add than what I just said it's no
there it's
it's quite likely that the judge will
issue a decision within the next 30 days
but that's a guess ultimately right and
the other person in the audience is
representative McGuire who did pass out
to all of us a proposed amendment to the
bill
um and I don't know whether you want to
hear from him at all that would be fine
with me but it is essentially a bill
that I based on a conversation I had
before uh this meeting with
representative Maguire who was good
enough to call me about it um
it uh essentially whittles down my bill
to a focus on the excess swept issue and
removes the changes that my bill makes
in in the low and moderate
or is it homeowner property tax rebate
program and uh we can talk about that
again later on or however you want to
handle it that's fine
thank you um I did talk to
representative McGuire a little bit
earlier and I promised him on a time so
if he can come forward and tell us about
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee for the record my name is Dan
McGuire I represent the town of Epsom I
went to the OLS last week and submitted
a bill to
um to change the Statewide education
property tax into a real tax because now
it's 100 fake in my opinion and
um they said to me you can't do it
because it's it's substantially similar
to representative Ames Bill the one
we're talking about now
and so I I don't think it is quite
frankly because it doesn't have all
those other features and it also has the
feature of lowering the amount so that
the total amount of property tax
collected in the state doesn't change
right so if you were to Simply make it
into a real tax such that the the
donor towns are exempt start paying well
that will collect for you an extra 25 28
million something like that and so
therefore
there's actually you know it's a raise
in taxes in some sense but if you but so
my my Amendment here is just the nut of
it which is to say
have all the municipalities pay their
actual tax
um and
um and the net result of that
if the donor towns start paying would be
a higher collection so the bill also
reduces the total number from the 363 by
25 million so that the total amount of
property tax paid in the state doesn't
change
um and that's the the essence of it
um and I guess
you know if you decide I could always go
to the rules committee and ask to
introduce this as a new bill for next
year maybe they would agree maybe they
wouldn't
um but you know if you decide just to
simply not consider this at this time
it's up to you I also handed out a
couple of
um supporting pieces of information and
I'm happy to take questions
representative fellows
um I'm I'm just wondering if you talked
to dra about the process of doing this
because it seems to me that if you're
going to have a state a real state tax I
agree with you that what we have now is
not a real state tax
seems to me they would have to collect
it they would have to send out the bills
and not everybody pays their property
tax on time so that they would be the
ones that would have to charge interest
or you know somehow do the collection on
their tax it could get pretty
complicated yes thank you for the
question so
the way it works now is people pay their
property taxes and their towns collected
you know all the all the four different
components right the the
um the town component the county
component the state and the and the
school component and so this bill
doesn't change that it just says instead
of taking that state component and
sending it to the school district send
it to dra instead so it's already being
collected it's already going somewhere
right it's going from the town to the
school district so it's just you know
redirects it to the other place so I
follow-up
okay
no I think we want to go really deep
into yeah I don't want to go too deep
into this because we're going to have
all right so representative Olney
text the amount that is going uh that is
supposed to be paid by the excess
uh payment towns like no
what why
it's going down to 338
yes because
it's already going down every single
year with inflation
well that's true too but
um because as a result of everyone
paying right and sending money to dra
there will be an extra
if you look at this spreadsheet roughly
28 million dollars going to dra slightly
less but but essentially I didn't my my
intention was not to raise property
taxes right so so in order to not do
that out on a Statewide basis right
because we're going to start charging
this would start charging a Statewide
property tax
you have to lower the whole amount
because certain places they're not
can't talk
yeah I just say that I I understand what
you're doing the uh currently
in the excess swept towns the excess is
the amount above
the adequate education and cost of
adequate education that is uh calculated
for the each of those towns and they've
raised more than that and the current
system allows them not only to retain
the sweat that's collected for adequate
education but also to retain the excess
above the cost of adequate education and
to apply it to the local school costs or
actually in some cases where they don't
have local school costs to apply it in a
negative sense as an offset against
Municipal rates
and what you're saying well that 30
million dollars will shave that excess
that amounts to is you came up with 25
million
we're going to shave that off and we're
going to set the new amount that needs
to be raised by this tax at 363 minus 25
and then dra will figure out the tax
rate across the state that produces that
amount and all that money will flow into
all right so as I said we'll we're going
to come back to this topic in another
another work session
one last comment representative the
original reason we ended up with the
system we've got is that the towns came
in and waved 28a at us and told us that
on we needed to pay them 10 million
dollars to collect it
uh
and I I do think it would be useful
before the next meeting if the dra would
figure out
whether there is excess cost
on on their end and from the local
that there that particularly the
municipalities would be complaining
about okay we'll follow up on that all
right uh this time I'm going to close
all right we have three Senate bills um
we'll conclude our work session and then
we'll go into exact session um
immediately following that
um SBE I'm going to open the work
session on SB 112 relative to paramutual
pools in historic horse racing
um do I have any comments
all right seeing none we'll close the
I'll now open the work session on sb190
relative to Advanced deposit account
wagering
this and this is going to this one as
well as SB 112 are going to be deferred
to another work session we will not be
executing these two today
comment representative just to say I
support that I think we need to have
that additional discussion okay thank
you thank you
given that I will close the work session
okay we're on our last uh bill of our
work session SB 191 I will now open that
work session it's relative to the road
toll registration surcharge for electric
vehicles and representative plett you
have a comment yes this is now moot
because the substance of it was included
all right um yes represent elberger just
a quick comment that uh the state of
Texas imposed a 200 uh surcharge on
owners of electric vehicles
so we look like we're relatively cheap
all right any other comments
um I meant cheap in the in the Good
Sense the word
all right I'm seeing none I will close
the work session on s p 191
uh I think what we're going to do right
now is take a five minute break but it's
I want to be back here precisely in five
minutes to start the uh exec session
all right
welcome back everyone we will now open
the exact session for hb15
representative Platt would you like to
make a motion I shall
I move interim study
or HP 15 and the logic is uh we wait
wait wait we got to get a second first
second
okay
who did it representative well
all right would you like to speak to
your motion
yes
um
the logic for this is that uh reduction
in the written business profit business
Enterprise tax often comes back in
better future
business profits tax but uh we we
included a be a reduction it was
included in hb2 a reduction speed up of
the elimination of the interest and
dividends tax and I think that's enough
for one biennium
representative almi thank you is that
going to be the blurb
we retain the bill
I think is interim starting to go to the
house yeah he goes before the house okay
yes we do need a report I'll make a
report
all right any other comments
seeing none the clerk will take the role
yes
let me make certain I write what bill it
is
okay uh 9 19
23 uh representative
acting chairman janigan
yes
uh
representative Smith
yes
representative ulery
Doucet yes represents Pillsbury yes
representative yes president
representative colcom
yes do they pronounce it correctly
okay thank you representative sodi yes
representative orrs yes representative
naughter yes
representative Army
yes representative Ames yes represents
Southworth yes
representative Malloy yes representative
Schomburg yes representative fellows yes
representative Bolton yes representative
alberger yes
representative leapley yes
representative Smith yes it's uh twenty
to zero
what about being 20 to zero interim
study passes
we'll now close the exact session on HB
15. Mr chairman yes let go on consent
right
that any objections to that going on
consent
all right I opened the exact session on
hb60 camping fees for non-residents
um representative spilsbury would you
like to make a motion thank you Mr chair
um I move itl on hb60
do we have a second representative
Doucet
oh
representative uh
Army
would you like to speak to your motion
yes thank you briefly
um
it was an interesting suggestion but I
don't think a compelling case was made
we risk alienating tourists and visitors
we raise questions about Administration
and priority booking for in in-state
residents
and there's even a constitutional issue
potentially under article 4 section 2 of
the U.S Constitution the privileges and
immunities clause if differential
pricing for State amenities and
privileges is too great it's a
constitutional problem
thank you any other comments
representative almi yes I don't think
I'd use the last argument since we were
told that Massachusetts does
apparently with immunity
all right seeing none we will the clerk
acting children again yes
uh representative Smith yes
representative ulery
representative descent yes
representative yes representative pled
votes yes representative colcom yes
representative Saudi yes representative
orrs yes representative naughter yes
representative Almy yes representative
Ames yes representative Southworth yes
representative Malloy yes representative
Schomburg yes representative fellows yes
representative Bolton yes representative
elberger yes representative leapley yes
that again is 20-0
Mr chairman the vote Yes point of order
yeah I'm I can't picture ever seeing
interim study on a consent calendar is
will someone check on that
we will check yeah because it seems
strange to me
and I'm not sure why it is a blurb it
even goes if it's in our study but well
we'll we'll figure it out did you want
to make a comment
representative Smith interim study isn't
a status it's a motion that will be
voted on by the whole house so it goes
on consent or the regular calendar just
like any other committee report so
that's why it does get a committee
report that will be printed in the house
calendar and and they'll vote
thank you very much for that
clarification so the vote being 20 to
nothing
the uh the vote passes itl HP 60. any
seeing none we'll put it on consent
close the exact session on hb60
now open the exec session on HP 100 to
and representative spilsbury I'd like to
make a motion yes thank you Mr chairman
I move interim study on HB 100.
foreign
do I have a second
second
representative
would you like to speak to your emotions
yes thank you Mr chair
um
we have already addressed the interest
in dividends tax in hb2 there may be
further discussion during the remainder
of the biennium so we uh our best
putting this interim study rather than
trying to vote it up or down and leave
that topic open
seeing none the clerk will take the role
thank you Mr acting chairman acting
chairman janigian
yes Representative Steven Smith yes
representative uluri yes representative
yes representative yes representative
votes yes representative colcom yes
representative Saudi yes representative
orrs yes representative uh naughter yes
representative almi
representative Ames yes representative
Southworth yes
representative uh Malloy yes
representative Schomburg yes
representative fellows yes
representative Bolton yes
representative elberger yes
representative liply yes representative
Jeffrey Smith yes 20-0
we're in a roll
of the vote being 20-0 interim study
passes any objection to the consent
calendar
seeing none will put it on consent
I'll open now the executive session for
HP 133
relative to repealing the communication
Services tax
representative uh Ellery would you like
do I have a second
second representative two set seconds up
would you like to speak to your motion
representative uluri
foreign
the interim study request was made uh
primarily because there are still some
outstanding questions regarding the
actual distribution of this tax and the
impact it would have on our emergency
9-1-1 system
um which I believe is dedicated to uh
receives some funding from this that
question has yet to be resolved
therefore
in Trump study
saying none the clerk will take the role
thank you Mr racking chairman knocking
chairman again yes Representative Steven
Smith yes representative Valerie
yes representative yes representative
civilsbury yes representative yes
representative colcom yes representative
Saudi yes representative orrs yes
representative naughter yes
representative Almy
representative Ames yes representative
Southworth yes
representative Malloy yes representative
Schomburg yes representative fellows yes
representative Bolton yes representative
elberger yes representative leapley yes
and a representative Jeffrey Smith yes
20-0
before being 20. devote being 20-0
interim study passes any objection to
the consent calendar for this one
seeing none will put this on a consent
I'll close the executive session on HP
133.
we'll now open the exec session for HP
145 relative to the collection of sales
taxes of foreign jurisdictions by New
Hampshire businesses
and representative Ellery would you like
to make a motion move uh Ito
do I have a second
by hoop
the lady in purple
representative Ellery would you like to
speak to your motion this one I would
um
with the way prioritization was
initially decreed New Hampshire
responded with a similar bill
after long and exhaustive committee work
and under the guidance of the Attorney
General a very different bill was
introduced to the house
we've also understand that as a result
of
both our work and the complaints from
other states a test case of sorts with
South Dakota established thresholds and
nearly all of the 45 sales tax states
have made modifications
along those lines only Colorado and
Louisiana have not done so and that is
due to a state constitutional issues
allowing local sales tax imposition
current New Hampshire law allows the
AG's office to intercede on behalf of
New Hampshire businesses made subject
across jurisdictional sales taxation
therefore this bill is unnecessary
thank you any other comments
seeing none the clerk will take the role
thank you acting chairman genegian yes
Representative Steven Smith yes
representative ulery yes representative
Doucette s representative yes
representative Pledge yes representative
colcom yes representative uh Saudi yes
representative orrs yes representative
naughter yes representative Almy yes
representative Ames yes representative
Southworth yes purpose of Malloy yes
representative Schaumburg yes
representative fellows yes
representative Bolton yes representative
yes representative lippley yes
the vote being 20-0 itl passes and uh
any objection to consent
seeing none it'll go on the consent
calendar
and now close the exact session on HP
145.
next up is the exact session for HB 220
we'll now open that
establishing a committee to study the
regulatory structure of charitable
gaming and representative Ames would you
like to make a motion certainly uh I
would you like to speak to your emotions
sure
um I think
the need for this bill is uh gone past
passed by we have a new commission
that's uh been established
um and that uh we'll be working through
this next year on issues related to
charitable gaming uh of of all different
kinds so it supersedes the need for this
uh Bill thank you any other comments
seeing none the clerk will take the role
okay
on HB 220 itl uh representative acting
chairman genegian yes Representative
Steven Smith yes representative Valerie
yes representative yes representative
spilsbury yes representative plant votes
yes representative colcum yes
representative sodi yes representators
yes representative naughter yes
representative almi
representative Ames yes representative
Southworth yes representative Malloy yes
representative Schomburg yes
representative fellows yes
representative Bolton yes
representative elberger yes
representative alipley yes represents
vote being 20-0 itl
passes and uh any objection to consent
being none
this will go on the consent calendar as
well
and now close the exact session on HP
and it looks like I will open the final
exec session of the day SB 191
relative to road toll registration
surcharges for electric vehicles
the representative spilsbury would you
like to make a motion yes thank you Mr
do I have a second
would you like to speak to your motion
yes thank you um
very briefly as was mentioned in the
work session the bill has become moot
because fees were incorporated into hb2
assessing 50 on a hybrid vehicle and a
hundred dollars on an electric vehicle
no need for the bill itl
thank you any other comments
sorry specifically I think that the law
in hb2 is not hybrid but plug-in hybrid
which is a very different object I'm
thank you for that clarification
representative Platt and I think you
should be immune quite frankly because
you have a very small Fiats and you have
huge
RAM trucks all paying the same gas tax
so you're just happen to be on the
fishing end of a non plug non-plug-in
vehicle
problem that we're having figuring out
how to charge this stuff
seeing none the clerk will take the role
thank you acting chairman janigian
yes Representative Steve Smith yes
representative Valerie yes
representative Doucet yes representative
Pillsbury yes
representative yes representative colcum
yes representative sodi yes
representative orrs yes representative
naughter yes represent me yes
representative Ames yes representative
Southworth
yes
representative Malloy yes per episode of
Schaumburg yes
representative fellows yes
representative Bolton yes representative
yes
representatively yes representative
Jeffrey Smith yes
20-0
the vote being 20-0 itl passes and do we
have any objections to consent seeing
well we've concluded our the seven bills
that um we're planning on executing
um I think we were very efficient today
thank you um moved right through it and
um
given that given that we have uh seven
left
it might be too much for one more uh
session uh one more committee meeting I
should say
um we will have to see whether we try to
do maybe maybe we'll set up a to try to
do all seven and then have another
committee meeting after that if we if we
can't get it done but um we'll have to
go go look at that we have
um about another six weeks to get these
retained bills done but not that we want
to stretch we don't want to stretch it
out to the very end so we will
try to schedule something fairly soon
and uh keep moving forward
anyone any questions come representative
Ames just wondering about timing for
uh the blurbs or reports on each of
these bills what
do you mean it's a good question I think
I've got to do one it's obviously going
to be very short but still I have to do
it
well we Pro yes uh Mr chair I don't
think we're in terrible how are we
because our next section was January 3rd
but we should still make it timely
enough so that we don't forget yeah I
would say we want it um
I mean we don't necessarily have to rush
it again into this calendar but I would
say it'd be good to have them all in by
Friday
yeah
yeah that's okay
representative
none of these bills go into the calendar
until
January
um
well we still want them in um to the
yeah Auto out of the out of the
committee
um so that's why I think it makes sense
just get it done if we set a longer time
uh frame then people are just going to
wait longer so I send them in to you or
um
or whatever yes uh send them to me okay
she gets a signal from you yeah okay
that's that's fine yeah
um or
sorry can you let us
um give us some idea of which day
the next meeting might happen fairly
soon because there are a lot of people
going in different directions well do we
have do we have weeks where people are
let me just represents leaving until a
third of October right after he gives
you that
after gets out of what he gives you his
blurb oh okay
2019. so you're uh representative Ames
yeah so I mean that that that is next
that would be next week
um the week
um
I'm gone half a week in the first week
of October so we probably uh so that we
don't delay this too far maybe we we try
to shoot for October 3rd Tuesday October
3rd how does that look for
for people before would be better but
what's that October 3rd is tight for me
well October 4th maybe it's only
available in the afternoon for me it's
only available in the afternoon for me
as well
um
how about Wednesday
no Wednesdays that is the fourth the
Tuesday so when are you back
representative Ames
um I've got in my mind October three oh
yeah what's the fifth one
I well I can't do the fourth fifth or
yeah I guess we could and I suggest the
following I guess we can do that I'm
gonna weigh that fourth through a
seventh as well oh you are okay
all right well yeah the following week
looks fairly
um
yeah how about um either Tuesday the
10th or Wednesday the 11th
okay
anybody else Wednesday that's just
10th is Tuesday
all right let's um
it's kind of an equal mix here of
Tuesdays and Wednesdays let's do Tuesday
all right so Tuesday the 10th we'll
uh I mean the one thing we have to
figure out is whether we can try to get
as many of these done as possible
whether we can I'll have to take a look
at them if we
you know we might want to start a little
bit earlier say around 9 30.
so that uh that's doable for everyone
all right so I think we're going to
shoot for Tuesday the 10th at 9 30. plan
on
um plan on a potential full day
and uh
you know if that changes I'll let you
know but for now
that'll be the plan
all right uh representative Ami you can
get Gen 4 to
call up the people you need to be there
yes right yeah we'll plan that
okay
all right thank you everyone
foreign